why did
stalinism for example lead to so much
bloodshed do you think and human
suffering is there any elements
within the ideas of marxism
that catalyzed
the kind of government
the kind of system that led to that
bloodshed
i don't think so i think there were many
things that led to the bloodshed and so
all that stalin's regimes did
and
you know i spent
10 years of my life
with another economist writing a book
about that to try to explain from a
marxist position
the rise and fall of the soviet union
you might want to take a look at it
sometime but
there i'm going to say a few things now
but all of those things are spelled out
in great detail with loads of empirical
evidence etc
um in that uh in that work
let me start with you know playing a
little bit with with hegel um
the biggest impact
that marxism had
on the soviet union
was really not so much what the soviet
union did
but what the rest of the world did
i mean you had a really interesting
move uh and i'll give you a parallel
from today
the move was
that
the old russian regime collapsed
world war one just it fell apart the
czar and all of that
it couldn't it couldn't survive it had
already been in trouble there was a
revolution in 1905 there was the loss of
the war to japan i mean if you know
russian history which i assume you do um
you'll know that there was a lot leading
up to
the collapse in in 1917
and in some ways it was fortuitous that
the
political group very small that could
seize the opportunity of that collapse
happen to be marxists you know
earlier on with karensky the first
government that tried
it wasn't people all that impressed by
marxism there was people more skeptical
and
would not have been called marxists
probably in
by history
they couldn't they tried they couldn't
lenin and his associates
were able to take over from them later
in that same year
the rest of the world though was
horrified
the rest of the world
saw marxism having taken this immense
leap from being a political party a
movement critical of capitalism yes
but still not
challenging the power now it had the
power and in a big country
and they freaked out
uh if you know american history uh this
country the leadership of this country
went completely berserk i mean we had a
repression of the left the likes of
which we had not seen before sat the
twenties were a time of palmer raids in
in boston the sacko vanzetti uh trials i
mean really
grim
hostility and you had the four countries
agreeing to invade the soviet union to
try to crush the revolution the u.s
britain france and japan all attacked 10
000 american troops
so what you had right away was a notion
in the west
that
this was
this was unthinkable this was there was
a great professor at princeton um
meyer forget his first name
who wrote this wonderful book
about all american foreign policy since
1917 has been obsessed
with russia even now this this fight
with ukraine is half about russia as if
russia still was the soviet union as if
people haven't figured out
that was a big change back in 1989 and
90. you know yeltsin and and putin are
not what what you had before or at least
they're not lenin um they may not be so
different from some of the other but in
any case
um
so you had one
factor was the utter isolation the utter
condemnation the global i mean
rosa luxemburg
is i mean i i assume you know the rosa
luxemburg is hunted down in the streets
of berlin she's a critic of lenin's by
the way but she's a leftist hunted down
and hacked into bits
killed so you're attributing some
he's surrounded some of the bloodshed
to the fact that basically the rest of
the world turned away
turned against turn against sort of
eternal guess is the better very
yeah i mean not in order of importance
but it's
it's a very important part of the
psychology of being you know
it's what you would call paranoid if
there weren't quite as much evidence
that indeed there was a lot to be afraid
of at that time nobody had ever done it
look you could see the effects of it by
stalin inventing the idea
which had no support at first
that you could have socialism in one
country that was thought to be
ridiculous that socialism was
internationalism marx was it marx was
against capitalism everywhere it was you
know uh workers of the world unite not
workers of russia unite
workers of the
he had to
go through a procedure of kind of coming
to terms with the fact that the
revolution he had in russia which was
tried in berlin was tried in munich was
tried in budapest was tried in seattle
here they all failed they all fit and
he's left
so the french would say
right yeah all along
um that's one
the second thing is economic isolation
russia is a poor country
and it needed
what it got before the war which were
heavy investments from the french and
the germans particularly but others too
now this was all cut off and you can see
the replay with the sanctions progress
it's we're to we're going to do it again
we're going to do it again we have to do
we we have the world is different and
the sanctions don't work but
they're going to try them they're going
to try
because it's the history but that
culture was
it's today is completely different
russia's a different place today but
russia has china and that changes
everything and they don't get that here
yet but they will yeah there's a very
complicated dynamic with china even with
india
um but portuguese sorry brazil
yeah sorry to say human nature may
change at a slower pace yes that that
does that has occurred to me as well i i
get that point so is there
can you steal man the case
or consider the case that there's
something about the implementation of
marxism
maybe because of the idealistic nature
of focusing on the working class and
workers unite
that naturally
leads to formation of a dictatorial
force a dictator
that says let us temporarily
give power to this person
to manage some of the details of how to
run the democracy
uh of
giving voice to the workers so that they
get to choose and then that naturally
leads to dictator and there's naturally
inhuman nature
power and absolute power as the old
adage goes
corrupts absolutely is it possible that
whenever you focus on marx's ideals
you're going to end up with a dictator
and often
when you give too much power to anyone
human a small number of people you're
going to get into huge amount of trouble
you you've pushed things together there
that i would
i think if you if you give putch there's
a good yeah
uh german um
the uh if you i remember i told you my
mother was born in germany and and then
your dad is french
yeah but he was born in mets if you know
european it's a city on the border of
france and germany if you come from this
alsatian
in german so they're german speaking
french
it's a bilingual because
it's been back and forth so many times
in medieval days already that it
literally you go from one store to
another the proprietor here is french
and the proprietor there is german but
they all speak both languages because
you don't speak either of them i speak
russian russian but not german ukrainian
no uh it took french for four years in
high school but i've forgotten all of it
i i remember the romance and the spirit
of the language but not the details i'm
sure i can remember um
if you allocate power
unequally
undemocratically
and you do it for a very long period of
time
and you do it on
many levels of ideology
it is not surprising that it sticks and
it stays and you can make a political
revolution or even an economic
revolution
and you will discover it has a life of
its own and it's going to take a long
time before people don't if you have a
religious tradition christianity
that prides itself on its
monotheism
and that it doesn't want to have
anything to do with the old greek
mythologies when there was zeus and
diana and all the others and they were
very human-like but instead we have one
who is the absolute beginning in it yeah
what are you doing you're teaching
people
an authority line that comes from the
individual if you have a sequence of
kings if in your feudal manner the lord
sits called the landlord and he has
unspeakable power
over everything that goes on
and you do this for thousands of years
yeah you can make a russian revolution
in 1917 but if you imagine you've gotten
away from all that people assume without
ever thinking about it
you're going to have
trouble stalin is figured
here
as the originator of his situation he
wasn't he had never had that power he
may have thought that but i don't
he's the product look the cuban people
made fidel
who really wasn't that kind of guy you
know he's a baseball playing lawyer
that's what he was yeah but they made
him into
tala so it's not
it's not the you're the
no no no it's it was the systems
feudalism the nature it was the
structures and institutions that
cultivated in people a mentality that
has its own rhythm and doesn't take
doesn't
follow the calendar of a political
revolution that's the fundamental
question is there's something about
communism
that creates someone mentality that
enables somebody like stalin or mao
no i think it's the social issues and
problems the society has that make them
then go to what they find familiar to
what seems to make sense and he's the
guy look let me give you an example from
american history
the republican party has traditionally
in this country been the party of
private enterprise and minimum
government
incomes trump runs for office in 2016
is elected okay what does he do he
commences the most massive
tax increase
and the most massive government
intervention
in the world of of economics that we
have had for
nobody says anything
the republicans
cave
and the democrats largely too
they cave he can he can
he can throw a tariff on anything he
gets up in front of the american people
and he says the chinese will pay the
tariff
that's not what a tariff is it's not how
a tariff works
he would flunk a cor a freshman course
in economics which everybody knows
everybody who teaches these courses no
it doesn't matter
he's still calling the shots
what is going on here is that a society
has come to a point where it can't solve
its problems and it begins what to tap
into older
forms and all of the laissez-faire and
all of the individualism
and suddenly the republican party is
gung-ho and now they're going to make
abortion illegal the government is
telling you what you can do with your
uterus
what
what
the government is being given more and
more and more and more power they're
hoping what do they like the government
no
they're desperate this is not a
pro-government and it wasn't in russia
isla they were in a desperate fix
and so
and he took advantage
you